vamos a pensar en otro escenario que
involucra proporciones en este caso
queremos la proporción del número de
manzanas el número de manzanas en
relación con el número de frutas que
tenemos aquí
el número de frutas y los invito a
pausar el vídeo y a pensar en la
respuesta por ustedes mismos
bueno cuál es el total de manzanas que
tenemos 2 468 tenemos 8 manzanas y cuál
es el total de frutas que tenemos ya
vimos que tenemos 8 manzanas y tenemos 3
6 9 12 naranjas el total de frutas es 8
+ 12 que es igual a 20 piezas de fruta
así que la proporción será 8 a 20 8 a 20
o si queremos escribir esto de una
manera reducida podemos dividir estos
dos números entre 44 es el máximo común
divisor y esta proporción es lo mismo
que 8 dividido entre 4 es igual a 2 y 20
dividido entre 4 es igual a 5 así que
tenemos 25 y esto tiene sentido si
dividimos todo en cuatro grupos y lo voy
a hacer aquí un grupo
dos grupos
tres grupos
y cuatro grupos vemos en cada grupo que
por cada dos manzanas tenemos uno dos
tres cuatro o cinco piezas de fruta por
cada dos manzanas tenemos cinco piezas
de fruta y esta es una buena oportunidad
para introducir otra manera de
representar proporciones y es usando la
anotación de fracciones así que también
podemos representar esta proporción como
sobre 5 podemos representar esta
proporción como la fracción 2 sobre 5 y
cuando usamos esta anotación de
fracciones debemos entender lo que esto
representa esto nos está diciendo que
dos quintos de la fruta son manzanas y
lo voy a escribir así dos quintos
de la fruta
son manzanas
una vez más esta es otra manera de
representar las proporciones podemos
decir que la proporción de manzanas en
relación con el número de frutas es 2 a
5 y escribirlo como aquí usando dos
puntos o como 25 o también podemos decir
que es dos quintos como una fracción
pero también esta anotación de
fracciones se puede leer como 2 a 5 y
esta oración en el contexto de las
proporciones
yo la leería como dos quintos de la
fruta son manzanas